فصول مقتليه لم تتكشف كامله بعد ولم يقل
اللاعبون الاساسيون في هذا الملف جل ما
لديهم الرئيس البيلاروسي الكسندر
لوكيشينكو كشف انه تلقى معلومات بدايه
العام الحالي عن التحضير لمحاوله اغتيال
واضاف انه ابلغ بالامر دون ان يكشف لا
مصدر التهديد ولا مصدر المعلومات واكد
لوكاشينكو ان بوتين لا يمكن ان يكون وراء
سقوط الطائره
تلقيت معلومات جاده للغايه من مصادر مطلعه
عن تحضيرات لاغتيال وفي غضون ساعتين ارسلت
هذه المعلومات الى بوتين برساله مشفره بعد
مرور بعض الوقت اتصلت
وتاكدت منه هل وصلت اليه تلك المعلومات ام
لا فاكد بريكوجين ان الرئيس الروسي نقل له
هذه المعلومات
اهميه كلام الرئيس البيلاروسي تكمن في
الدور الذي لعبه بعد محاوله التمرد التي
قادها بريغوجين في روسيا قبل شهرين انذاك
دخل في وساطه بين الكرملين افضت الى اتفاق
بنقل عناصر الى قاعده عسكريه بيلاروسيه
قرب منسك وبعد ان خرج بريكوجين من الصوره
اعلن لوكاشينكو وهو حليفه الكرملين المقرب
ما قد يكشف مصير الالاف من مقاتل المجموعه
فالقوام الرئيسي لفاجنر باقي في الاراضي
البيلاروسيه كما قال وان دعت الحاجه فقد
يتم استخدام المزيد منهم بحسب لوكاشينكو
في الاثناء تقول الولايات المتحده ان خطر
المجموعه مازال قائما وان التقييم مستمر
لبحث التداعيات ما حدث على عملها لاسيمه
في القاره الافريقيه